et je sais qu'on va me tomber dessus
vous avez des candidats qui chantent
mieux que le jury on fait ça
[Musique]
et donc le magazine Public révèle que
l'animateur serait un véritable tombeur
et à trois femmes qui ont témoigné et
qui ont parlé de lui alors voilà ce que
dit la première voilà et elle dit
c'était des je t'aime en permanence tout
le temps d'autres je veux t'épouser on
va vivre bientôt dans ma maison de
campagne chez moi parce que soi-disant
ils travaillaient voilà et pendant qu'il
voyait cette femme là il y avait une
deuxième femme qui voyait qui elle dit
on s'est rencontré par un intermédiaire
d'une amie en commun il m'a fait des
grandes promesses me comble de mots
d'amour évidemment les deux ne savent
pas qu'elles existent pas encore non pas
encore alors elle dit aussi d'autres
phrases cette deuxième femme lors d'un
weekend en amoureux une fille dont le
prénom s'affiche sur ton téléphone ne
cesse d'appeler donc elle a piqué le
téléphone elle a dit qu'il y avait une
fille c'est un indice et s'éloigne pour
répondre ça aussi un vrai truc et c'est
loin de pour répondre il tourne ton
téléphone voilà et donc la fille dit
profitant de son sommeil je regarde son
téléphone je comprends cette fille était
avec lui depuis 4 ans avec quatre ans
qu'il était avec deux femmes en même
temps et je termine l'histoire et ce
sera à vous de vous lâcher il y a une
troisième femme du coup qui arrive
également et cette troisième femme
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit
il est avec elle depuis 8 ans comment
reconnaître que votre femme ou votre mec
vous trompe première chose c'est la plus
classique c'est qu'il ne vous laisse
plus accéder à son téléphone ça
malheureusement
tu décides une au début de ta vie moi
c'est pas le cas tout le monde mon code
sur moi donc il y a pas de souci que tu
dis clairement à tout le monde le code
je donne pas donc tu as pas tout d'un
coup quand tu deviens amoureux quelqu'un
de dire eh t'as pas mon code non c'est
pas de donner le code mais c'est par
exemple de laisser son téléphone comme
ça à côté c'est nez et de laisser les
petites notifications
je connais plein de copains contre trois
téléphones officiels ils en a un autre
qui est planté
vous avez vu le premier prime juste un
petit mot qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé voilà globalement est-ce que vous
avez aimé pas aimé aussi qu'est-ce que
tu as préféré qu'est-ce que t'as pas
aimé qu'est-ce que t'as déçu moi je suis
triste de ne pas retrouver mes
professeurs
le château et les profs ouais et on fait
de nous les élèves de futurs artistes ah
c'est vrai ah c'est toi aussi vous étiez
d'accord aussi vous voulez retrouver les
anciens profs moi je le corps avec la
prod a fait un bon choix je pense que
casting des chanteurs est bon et le
casting des profs est très bon j'adore
le prof de théâtre
on aurait pu peut-être avoir une
personne comme Oscar contrairement etc
ce que je vous dis un truc au Canada par
exemple au Canada ils ont fait revenir
les gagnants qui ont chanté avec un
nouveau candidat moi j'étais persuadé
que le prime couvrait avec vous vraiment
c'était c'était quasiment tous les
anciens ceux qui ont marqué vraiment la
saison qu'elle est danser machin
l'ouverture je pensais que ce serait
vous ça aurait été est-ce que vous avez
été contacté pour le début est-ce que
est-ce qu'ils ont hésité est-ce qu'ils
vous ont appelé ou pas du tout pas du
tout alors il y a eu les 20 ans de la
Star Ac donc je pense qu'il y a ça aussi
jouer sur le fait qu'on ne soit pas là
au début mais moi j'aurais trouvé normal
que Jennifer en tout cas commence
l'émission voilà parce que c'est quand
même une des révélations de la Star Ac
et si pas la plus grande pour toi le
niveau des candidats que tu en penses le
niveau est haut et
trop par rapport à ce que vous
connaissez de nos de nos années c'est
vrai que le problème commence fort après
moi c'est le casting professoral qui me
dérange pas pourquoi
qu'est-ce qu'il a et parce que il y a
certains candidats c'est un peu une
critique que j'avais émise sur The Voice
vous avez et je sais qu'on va me tomber
dessus vous avez des candidats qui
chantent mieux que le jury
[Musique]
avec Laurent faut pas oublier qu'il
donne une chaîne de télévision c'est une
entreprise qui va faire des bénéfices et
la cible principale c'est la responsa le
responsable et la responsable des achats
qui préfèrent voir un beau mec même quel
que soit son âge en train de présenter
l'émission que de voir une femme
pour expliquer au public la responsable
des achats c'est la femme généralement
qui est responsable des achats dans le
foyer qui va chez Carrefour et qui a
moins de 50 €
les hommes vieillissent mieux l'amitié
c'est mieux la télévision c'est un
métier d'image ça mettait de séduction
et je suis désolé mais ça on enfonce
peut-être des portes ouvertes mais un
homme en général de bien moi je suis
plus beau qu'il y a quand j'avais 30 ans
je trouve que là pour le coup c'est
hyper sexiste de dire un truc pareil
c'est la vérité
je parlais pas de moi là je parle d'une
généralité les hommes biais souvent
mieux sont enceinte tout le temps pour
dire c'est complètement faux une femme
je peux avoir Isa Isa et après on est en
train de mélanger plusieurs choses et de
raisons en ce qui concerne le ce que dit
Laurent effectivement moi
de base qui adore regarder la télévision
sur les grandes émissions populaires
fédératrice je suis désolé en tant que
femme je préfère voir un mec je me
présenter un grand programme et
effectivement qu'au présenter
éventuellement co-présente avec une
fille mais j'irai je regarde avec plus
de réticences un programme présenté par
une femme
si petit à petit moi j'ai toujours senti
que j'avais un problème d'alcool c'est à
dire que quand je buvais pas de la
semaine c'est parce que je me retenais
de boire j'avais vraiment envie de boire
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps et puis à partir du moment où j'ai
accepté de l'alcool tous les soirs les
angoisses sont devenus de plus en plus
importantes et à un moment donné un jour
vous vous levez un matin et vous êtes
incapable de fonctionner c'est-à-dire
vous êtes tellement pris d'angoisse vous
êtes tellement mal que vous êtes
incapable de fonctionner donc j'ai
commencé à boire un petit peu de whisky
dans mon café ça a commencé comme ça et
puis de fil en aiguille je suis arrivé à
boire toute la journée du matin au soir
arrive c'est pas la télé il en parle
souvent et il a il s'est souvent exprimé
aussi sur le fait qu'il a eu des pensées
très obscures il a suicide très sérieuse
donc ça aussi il faut le dire parce
qu'en général c'est à ça que ça mène et
alcoolisme monte d'un nom mais
l'alcoolisme dur comme le sien oui
le 88 à 96 donc avant votre premier mari
comme ça pas de souci vous vivez une
aventure amoureuse avec Prince oui tout
à fait mais c'est quoi ça
je l'ai connu vraiment il est encore
dans 4 ans
il était beau comme un dieu 2 ans
oui il y a eu des allers-retours j'ai
passé du temps à Minneapolis bien sûr
mais ça s'est fait comment
c'était le premier le premier concert de
ma vie de concert de ma vie c'est à dire
j'arrive dans la salle il y a le staff
qui m'attire qui me prend comme par le
collet et qui me met dans dans le truc
VIP ah oui et donc à la deuxième chanson
je reçois il y avait son garde du corps
qui me donne un papier avec son avec un
bic parce qu'en fait il m'avait tendu le
micro pour chanter moi je connaissais
aucune de ces chansons
et tout le monde chantait les paroles et
etc et dans le micro le papier entre
deux chansons et je lis et j'avais
emmené mes copains avec moi j'avais dit
non non je rentre pas là-dedans si je
peux pas prendre mes potes avec moi donc
il y a mes copains de chaque quoi et et
c'était marqué voilà j'aimerais beaucoup
vous rencontrer non j'aimerais beaucoup
vous rencontrer après le concert et
cetera rendez-vous dans tel endroit